nous sommes le vendredi 12 juin merci de
nous rejoindre sur l'antenne de télé fil
78 pour une nouvelle édition du journal
dans l'actualité la campagne à
destination des jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
sans qualification revient aux formes et
a été lancée voici quelques semaines ils
sont près de 500 à s'être déjà manifesté
les oeuvres et d'anish kapoor dans le
parc du château de versailles font
toujours polémique à près de dix mille
signatures déjà rassemblées par une
pétition et le groupe municipal
d'opposition versailles familles à venir
qui demande le retrait de cette
exposition invité l'une des élues de ce
groupe valérie est au big et puis en
seconde partie du journal l'essentiel de
la semaine mobilité de demain à poissy
la mobilisation face à la fermeture de
la maison de l'environnement à magny les
hameaux et puis inauguration d'une place
à versailles en mémoire de jonathan sang
de leurs victimes de mohamed merah la
fédération nationale du bâtiment qui
poursuit son congrès à versailles en
profite pour célébrer les 50 ans de la
section des yvelines deuxième et dernier
jour ce vendredi avec au programme le
passage de relais au nouveau président
de l'antenne locale mais aussi un
hommage appuyé aux quelques 6800
artisans et entrepreneurs du bâtiment
des yvelines et quelques trente six
mille salariés travaillant dans ces
structures rappelons cependant que
depuis 2008 le bilan est contrasté avec
20% au moins là d'activité même si le
bâtiment représente toujours et 10% de
l'activité économique des yvelines le
ministère de l'éducation lance une
nouvelle campagne contre le décrochage
scolaire revient en forme et c'est son
nom doit permettre à chaque jeune
d'obtenir une qualification
nous sommes allés au service académique
d'information et d'orientation pour en
savoir plus
si vous avez entre 16 et 25 ans que vous
êtes uniquement titulaire du brevet ou
du bac mais sans compétence ou si vous
n'avez aucun diplôme
alors vous êtes éligibles au droit à la
formation dans le cadre du plan de lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire le
ministère de l'éducation entend diviser
par deux le nombre de jeunes sortants
sans qualification du système éducatif
en 2017
concrètement l'opération baptisée
revient en forme et permettent un
accompagnement personnalisé
les inscriptions se font depuis internet
nous ces messages nous le recevons ici
ensuite ils sont redistribuées auprès de
l'ensemble des centres d'information et
d'orientation de l'académie de
versailles et celio et à partir de là
les jeunes sont contactés pour un
rendez-vous sous quinzaine et les
demandes sont déjà importantes depuis le
19 mai en quelques semaines d'existence
500 jeunes de l'académie ont déjà fait
une demande l'aide dans le cadre de
cette opération
quand on étudie plus précisément les
demandes on s'aperçoit que pour la
plupart se sont d'ores et déjà des
jeunes diplômés qui ne sont pas
forcément en attente d'un complément de
formation mais qui sont plutôt en
attente d'un accès à l'emploi
on s'aperçoit bien que en analysant plus
finement la demande la demande n'est pas
nécessairement un retour en formation
mais plutôt une poursuite de deux
commandos parcours personnel à travers
l'accès à un emploi
donc on va voir avec les différents
partenaires de travail notamment les
missions locales
on travaille beaucoup en binôme avec les
missions locales avec les cfa on va voir
ce qu'il va être possible de proposer un
sac à chacun de ces jeunes avant la mise
en place du dispositif l'académie
accueillait déjà chaque année 300 jeunes
souhaitant réintégrer un parcours de
formation
après murakami ou encore jeff koons
cette anish kapoor artiste britannique
natif de bombay qui expose au château de
versailles les parisiens l'avaient déjà
découvert en 2011 lors de l'exposition
monumenta au grand palais cette fois ci
son travail fait polémique bonjour
valérie d'aubigny vous êtes élu à
versailles dans l'opposition sur la
liste versailles familles à venir et
vous avez écrit à catherine pégard la
directrice de l'établissement public du
château vous souhaitez le retrait de ses
oeuvres
est-ce que vous avez une réponse nous
n'avons pas de réponse marc mpay gare
est occupée elle est actuellement au
grand congrès guindy greenberger à
vienne et elle ne nous a pas répondu
mais j'espère qu'elle le fera que nous
aurons l'occasion d'avoir cette
discussion
cette discussion apaisé je crois qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on prenne le temps de
comprendre ensemble sans sans passion
sans sans caricature quelle est la place
réelle de l'art contemporain justement
pour être très clair là pour mieux
comprendre votre position est ce que
vous êtes opposé à l'art contemporain à
versailles en tout cas au château ou
uniquement à cet artiste
alors justement c'est très très
intéressant l'actualité nous donne
l'occasion de mettre en perspective si
j'ose dire
plusieurs plusieurs oeuvres
contemporaines actuellement que l'on
peut voir actuellement à versailles
vous avez certainement ici parler de
l'inauguration du bosquet du théâtre
d'auch qui était magnifique qui est une
oeuvre contemporaine avec qui utilise la
lumière le mouvement l'eau et de manière
en même temps respectueuse du lieu et de
l'esprit du lieu
et c'est là où monsieur k pour lui
arrive avec une heure une oeuvre
préfabriqués qui a déjà été exposée à
milan il ya quelques années par exemple
sous un autre sous un autre nom enfin
c'était dirty corner toujours mais il la
ilaha illa subtilement glissé le vagin
de la reine histoire de d'agitation
j'avais pas lu mon fils et voilà c'est
pas nos conceptions qui a été par la
suite donné ont versé du spécial
versailles on va dire et il arrive avec
son oeuvre préfabriqués qu'il pose bien
en plein milieu dans la perspective
alors que pour le bosquet du théâtre
d'auch le paysagiste a fait extrêmement
attention les arbres ne dépasseront pas
les 17 mètres prévus par le nôtre pour
s'inscrire dans la perspective c'est un
art subtil l'art l'art d'un jardin 1 et
nice et sophia d'artistes qui ne
respectent pas le travail qui a été mené
mais sur les précédentes expositions par
exemple je citais murakami kunz tout à
l'heure alors si ça vous avez bergé elle
aussi nous avait dérangé car elle
s'inscrivait à l'intérieur du château de
versailles devant à l'intérieur du choc
il n'y en a pas mal effectivement ce ne
sont que les jardins alors notre espoir
c'est que pour la prochaine ce soit tout
à fait à l'extérieur dans des endroits
qui lui conviennent davantage
on va écouter l'artiste justement lors
d'inaugurations la semaine dernière et
lui il voudrait bien évidemment qu'on ne
retienne pas uniquement cet aspect de
sexualité écouter d'après wang
en oeuvre dont nous parlons dirty corner
qui se situent plus bas dans l'entrée
est une oeuvre qui possède comme idée
principale un instant d'obscurité j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de l'idée de
déterrer quelque chose de l'extraire un
des moments inévitable lorsque l'on des
terres quelque chose est liée au corps
et à la sexualité
je pense que c'est inéluctable je suis
heureux que l'oeuvre se retrouvent ici
comme un sujet de discussion mais ce
n'est pas là le véritable objectif
je suis d'avis que la qualité d'une
oeuvre correspond à la diversité
d'essences qui peuvent y être apportées
la sexualité correspond seulement à l'un
d'entre eux je pense que se concentrer
uniquement sur ceux ci relèvent un peu
de l'hystérie et est utilisé dans
d'autres intérêts que celui de l'art
alors avant tout je dirais venez voir
l'oeuvre
vous verrez qu'en réalité il s'agit de
sexualité oui et non kapoor je pense que
se concentrer uniquement sur ceux ci
révèlent un peu de l'hystérie est
utilisé dans d'autres intérêts que celui
de l'art vous avez une réponse
alors est-ce que c'est quand j'entends
le mot intérêts et monsieur k pour
effectivement cherche l'intérêt c'est
vrai un intérêt un intérêt spéculatif on
le sait bien c'est cet art international
qui profitent de vitrines comme celles
de versailles d'une et 6 pour venir se
poser et ouvrir le tiroir caisse et
partie différée pendant d'autres intel a
d'autres à d'autres fins en fait oui ça
c'est étrange vous voyez comme il glisse
il glisse subtilement enfin le croit-il
quelques quelques allusions sexuelles
mais c'est pas ça qui nous dérange
absolument pas quoi cavage un gros vagin
rouillé je trouve pas ça très fort
c'était pas lui c'était pas le butin ce
n'était pas le but de l'artiste
voilà une amante à leur montrer il a été
très subtil dans sa campagne marketing
en le suggère en tout cas mais ce n'est
pas ça qui nous dérange d'ailleurs le
château les jardins du château recèle
mille à lui
on a l'amour aux passions mais tout ça
dans un quelque chose qui est ordonnée
qui est intelligent alors que là on
arrive avec avec du lourd
un matériau lourd des allusions lourde
et puis il a commencé son entretien là
avec vous en évoquant en évoquant la
mort le noir ce n'est pas l'esprit de
versailles est justement le nôtre par
cette perspective qui est sans doute une
des plus belles du monde
subtilement en elle le regard vers vers
plus au vert plus loin vers plus grands
là on le voit bien ordre dans l'ordre il
a voulu amener du désordre
je ne sais pas si lui supporterait le
chaos dans son désordre à lui j'aimerais
le savoir j'aimerais savoir si une
performance il l'a percevraient comme
dollar ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
demandent de venir voir et de et
effectivement c'est comme ça qu'il faut
il faut évidemment vous êtes rendus sur
place que vous avez découvert les
oeuvres
oui j'ai passé du temps parce que je
trouve que les il faut donner du temps à
l'oeuvre pour voir ce qu'elle nous donne
les ondes qu'elle dégage
j'ai passé du temps dans le jardin aussi
en écoutant les personnes qui venaient
parfois de très loin parfois très très
déçu très dérangé très amer parce que
parce que pour certaines elles font le
voyage de leur vie elles sont
extrêmement déçus
en passant du temps près de près de
cette oeuvre je n'ai pas je n'ai pas vu
je n'ai pas vu de joie et de détente
autour de moi c'est en repartant en
longeant le bassin de latone qui vient
d'être refait qui est éclatant de
fraîcheur de pureté d'énergie d'
équilibre que là on peut commencer à
avoir un petit battement de coeur
effectifs et des contrastes qui était
souhaité par 6 alors finalement il a
réussi c'est cet art martial et si
finement juste pour élargir sur les
autres oeuvres qui sont présentées y en
a dix ils font tout et son exposé à
versailles bon tu dans la salle du jeu
de paume qui elle aussi elle fait
polémique juste in the corner on va
revoir les images de tout à l'heure
cette cire qui a été projetée sur un mur
dans la salle du jeu de paume
est ce que cette oeuvre là vous dérange
aussi est ce que d'ailleurs les autres
oeuvres vous dérange ou c'est le dirty
corner le surnommé le vagin de la haine
donc posé sur le tapis vert qui vous
dérange
je dirais que c'est dirty corner qui
pose le plus de problème parce qu'il
s'inscrit là dans la perspective de
manière écrasante et orgueilleuse les
autres oeuvres
pour certaines sont des effets d'optique
miroir très beaux matériaux
ça c'est très intéressant à observer ses
intérêts alors parlons de celle ci que
l'on voit actuellement elle ça elle
tombe là dans la salle du jeu de paume
dans un angle elle est extrêmement
violente elle et elle et elle est forte
c'est vrai mais elle n'a pas sa place
ici elle et elle est elle aussi
volontairement provocatrice et 7 cette
manière de provoquer pour convaincre
n'est pas la plus grande porte pour
rentrer dans la communication entre
l'artiste et son public
l'artiste qui souhaitait malgré tout à
respecter ce lieu c'est ce qu'il nous a
dit je vous propose d'écouter un second
extrait j'ai pas mal réfléchi à toute
l'histoire de l'élaboration de cet
endroit au courage de louis xiv et de
celui de lenôtre pour réaliser cette
perspective exceptionnel perspectives
sur le monde dirons-nous avec une
dimension centrale et une assurance
immense avec aussi des répercussions sur
la politique tout au long de
l'élaboration en tant qu'artiste on ne
peut l'y disent il question
finalement une star pour respecter ce
lieu à niger venu avec beaucoup de
respect en tout cas anish kapoor parle
il parle autour de son oeuvre et un
discours et ça c'est très très
particulier à l'art contemporain
le discours fait partie de l'oeuvre
c'est prendre à la société long mais
c'est une réflexion plus profond mais
effectivement le les moyens de l'époque
si on se projette ça il ya quelques
quelques siècles on imagine bien qu'ils
auraient eu le nôtre ou autres qui
auraient été sollicités de la même
manière et invité sur les plateaux télé
pour parler de leurs oeuvres bien sûr il
en est les entendrait parler et il en
aurait parlé il aurait parlé de l'oeuvre
ce qu'elle dégage ce qu'elle est mais
pour la comprendre pour entrer dans en
contact avec l'oeuvre
il n'aurait pas fallu le discours vous
voyez c'est ce que je veux dire d'accord
aujourd'hui il y a un discours qui est
il ya une médiation j'entendais
quelqu'un l'autre jour près de près de
l'oeuvre dirty corner qui disait il faut
de la pédagogie
eh bien non une oeuvre d'art elle elle
se donne elle se donne à voir
on l'aperçoit on voit où est le plus où
est le moins les ondes qu'elle dégage
on imagine que l'exposition ne va pas
être retirée elle est présente jusqu'au
1er novembre
malgré tout en tant qu'élu en tout cas
lui d'opposition à versailles vous
souhaitez engager le débat que pour la
suite
les autres artistes par exemple soit
associé autocad la parole de la
municipalité soit entendu parce que vous
êtes dans l'opposition mais le maire de
versailles n'a pas apprécié non plus il
a glissé un un tweet à c'est assez clair
son seul commentaire officiel
anish kapoor dérape sur le tapis vert
voilà c'était le tweet de françois de
mazières qui n'apprécie pas non plus
françois de mazières en quelques mots a
dit beaucoup nous mêmes
fabien bouglé moi avons voulu réagir
vite notre beau pays je reprécise
versailles famille l'avenir c'est cela
pour versailles familles à venir
nous avons voulu dire haut et fort et à
la bonne personne madame pégard qui en a
la responsabilité que pour pour la
dernière fois
il ne faut plus laisser cet espace à ces
gens qui viennent finalement phagocyter
un patrimoine s'en nourrir il le dit
très clairement il a des paroles assez
cynique aniche qu'amour kapoor
j'en ai assez de faire des cadeaux à la
france la prochaine fois qu'on voudra
m'inviter il faudra avoir l'argent et ne
pas demander que je le trouve moi même
il ya beaucoup de cynisme là nous
voudrions que ce que cet art spéculatifs
internationale ne viennent plus
finalement parasiter cet endroit sans
nourrir et non pas entrer en dialogue
avec le passé mais plutôt le bâillonner
et lui faire les poches c'est un peu
c'est un peu triviale ce que je vous dis
là mais c'est véritablement comme ça que
ses ressentis par par nos concitoyens
une pétition qui a été lancée sur
versailles un peu plus de dix mille
signatures vous l'avait relayé cette
pétition il ya cette lettre qui a été
écrit donc à catherine pégard la
directrice de l'établissement public du
château de versailles démobilisation ou
autre qui va être prévues par la suite
oui je pense que la mobilisation va
aller croissant l'oeuvre enfin les
oeuvres sont là théoriquement jusqu'au
mois de novembre
ce qui est intéressant c'est que chacun
réagit avec ce qu'il est bon avec ses
compétences avec son domaine d'action
naturel il ya eu un excellent article
récemment sur figaro vox par une juriste
donc cet aspect juridique comment une
oeuvre vient s'inscrire dans une oeuvre
préexistantes les ses droits et ses
devoirs très intéressant il y a des gens
qui ont des modes d'action plus direct
il y à il ya la parole il y a des
paroles de philosophie il ya des paroles
d'artistes contemporains qu'ils aient
eux aussi il faut penser à eux en ont
assez que la place soit toujours prises
par ces gens qui arrivent qui arrivent
de manière grossière et qui finalement
occupe le terrain merci valérie domini
élus donc du groupe versailles familles
à venir à versailles d'être passé sur ce
plateau vous êtes opposé à ses oeuvres
on l'a bien compris de capurro el chato
il ya cette pétition qui a été lancée
plus de dix mille signatures collectées
le journal se poursuivront passer à
l'essentiel de la semaine
comme chaque vendredi le résumé de la
semaine lundi nous revenions dans ce
journal sur cette décision de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de fermer la
maison de l'environnement à magny les
hameaux après la maison de la poésie est
c'est une autre structure qui est donc
directement concernés par les coupes
budgétaires un collectif de soutien est
en train de se constituer un appel à
pétition a été lancée en l'honneur de
cette maison environnement dont le
personnel qui aura lui aussi mené au
réseau des médiathèques alain le vote
l'ancien maire de magny les hameaux fer
de lance du collectif de soutien la
maison l'environnement en ce 5 juin dix
ans jour pour jour après l'inauguration
du site
plusieurs habitants se sont rassemblés
pour protester contre cette fermeture
annoncée par la communauté
d'agglomération en raison de la baisse
des dotations et des économies à faire
il ya des choix à faire on peut toujours
faire des choix et dans les périodes de
crise je pense que le mieux c'est quand
même de mettre l'argent là où c'est le
plus utile c'est-à-dire la culture et
l'éducation la santé la vie éducative
l'environnement qui est important
aujourd'hui est le sport de masse la
perte de dotation
cette année de l'état pour la casse qui
c'est l'équivalent en gros du loyer du
vélodrome
pourquoi ce serait seulement les
citoyens qui ferait des efforts on peut
peut-être demander de renégocier le
contrat de ppp avec bouygues pour voir
si on peut pas arrangé les choses
depuis une semaine une pétition circule
elle a recueilli plus de 650 signatures
c'est un endroit qui est hyper
symbolique pour 3 au changement et voilà
qui est un lieu pain qui voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de sens dans notre vie au
quotidien et dans notre engagement
j'ai déjà utilisé cette maison dans le
cadre d'une formation professionnelle
puisque je suis enseignant et la
communauté d'agglomération elle a pour
mission aussi de répartir d'activité sur
le territoire et il faut savoir que la
ville de magny-les-hameaux
malheureusement est un petit peu
excentré et si on
ni un plan pas de lieux comme ça qui
peuvent attirer des événements on risque
d'en faire une ville dortoir la majorité
la casse qui explique que les missions
environnement seront redéployés au sein
du réseau des médiathèques cela ne
convainc pas le réseau des médiathèques
adea peut avoir des démissions multiples
mais s'agissant de la science et de
l'environnement je vous dis pour
organiser des événements comme des
formations comme des amphithéâtres des
projections etc
c'est pas le même équipement c'est pas
la même capacité d'accueil c'est parce
pas le même public à la motte espère
maintenant constituer un collectif plus
large en incluant les usagers de la
maison de la poésie à guyancourt dont la
fermeture a également été actée mardi
l'actualité locale marquée à à poissy
par les mauvais audace depuis à 2006
movéo fédère les acteurs de l'automobile
autour de la mobilité de demain et
chaque année les mauvais oeil se
permettent donc de dresser un bilan et
de définir de nouvelles perspectives
recharger sa voiture électrique grâce à
une remorque ce sera bientôt possible
ce produit de l'entreprise heavy noise
basée à poissy le détendeur étaient
présentés aujourd'hui au mot vod il a pu
être développé grâce à l'aide de mauvais
au mauvais lot c'est un pôle de
compétitivité qui favorise l'émergence
de projets innovants
l'existence de ce type de de forums et
de kloster est très important et puis
mauvais ou nous a aidés également sous
l'angle de la labellisation de notre
projet pour aider
accès bus avec financement et véhicules
électriques applications et logiciels
intelligents ou logiciels de simulation
24 produits innovants du secteur de la
mobilité sont mises à l'honneur
ils sont parfois étonnants comme ce
simulateur de logiciels élaboré à
versailles il est configuré pour aider
les constructeurs à faire évoluer leurs
véhicules sur les problématiques de
consommation et de sécurité aujourd'hui
on m'a vraiment
un marché qui est en train de devenir de
plus en plus important on a des capteurs
à bas coûts comme la caméra le traçons
le radar qui sont déjà deux présents
plus présents dans le véhicule et on a
un potentiel qui reste assez élevé en
termes de d'autres formes de perception
un des 24 projets présentés se verra
remettre ce soir une récompense un
mobility à ward
une façon d'encourager la démarche
d'innovation de ces entreprises on
adéquation avec les objectifs fixés par
le gouvernement
nous voulons montrer que les pôles de
compétitivité ça fonctionne et qu'on
passe vraiment du projet de r&d pour
produits sur le marché et donc ses lacs
ce qu'on a voulu donner aujourd'hui à
cette journée en montrant les produits
issus des projets de r&d initié grâce à
mme oseo et grâce à l'interaction
l'écosystème d'innovation animé par le
pôle des innovations diffusé bientôt
très largement pour les particuliers ou
les professionnels depuis neuf ans 375
projets ont déjà été labellisé par le
pôle dont 50 % ont obtenu des
financements publics
la ville de versailles a inauguré
mercredi un square nom de jonathan
sandler ce professeur d'origine juive a
été assassiné par mohamed merah à
toulouse en 2012 j'en attends sans
douleur était très attaché à cette
commune des yvelines il a fréquenté
versailles pendant son enfance il s'est
également marié à la synagogue
la commune qui a donc voulu lui rendre
hommage michael et demi d'euros et
william elle était sur place
un square pour ne pas oublier un jardin
public au nom de jonathan sandler a été
inauguré ce mercredi le professeur
d'origine juive est l'une des victimes
de la tuerie de mohamed merah il a été
abattu devant l'école ozar hatorah de
toulouse avec ses deux fils arieh et
gabriel le 19 mars 2012
la commune de versailles tenait à leur
rendre hommage je suis très sensible à
la mémoire comme je les dis on se
souvient toujours de nom de l'assassin
jamais des victimes et l'aoma en plus si
dans un milieu scolaire
mon fils voulait tout est sa vocation
d'enseigner donc en plus à versailles
est une ville qu'il aimait donc il a été
scout à versailles il a été l'élève de
marcel tassencourt donc si elle pouvait
pas mieux on est tous aux souffrances
c'est pas facile pour nous ce sont des
leurres pour sa famille
il a perdu un fils de petits enfants moi
j'ai perdu un fils ça c'est dur c'est
dur mais il faut rester debout ils font
passer ce message de paix le vivre
ensemble au respect de l'autre c'est
important des personnalités du monde
religieux et politiques étaient présents
le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve était en déplacement dans le
cadre de la journée nationale d'hommage
aux victimes doit être là pour dire
qu'on n'oublie pas le martyre de ceux
qui sont tombés sous le feu de barbares
dire aussi que la république est plus
forte que certaines rappeler ce que sont
les valeurs de la république a rappelé
l'attachement qui est le nôtre à faire
en sorte que l'antisémitisme n'est
aucune place dans la société française
parce que l'antisémitisme c'est le
contraire de la république
on a mis une pierre sur la mémoire
collective la mémoire nationale et ça me
semble très important dans un lieu des
enfants enjouée le monde entier
villetelle mu ne tient que par le
souffle des enfants qui étudient ici ce
sera le souffle et les rires des enfants
qui rient qui joue qui redonnera vie à
un jeune anglais rarissime d'air gabriel
sandler aimé ramond sont au total c'est
une centaine de personnes qui a assisté
à cette inauguration du square jonathan
sans gloire tout autre sujet à présent
c'est demain samedi que débute parole de
jardinier un rendez vous pour les
passionnés de jardinage amateurs et
professionnels à travers le département
des animations visites de jardins privés
des conférences le parrain alain baraton
jardinier-en-chef du grand parc du
château de versailles étaient en plateau
cette semaine écoutez j'ai eu l'immense
bonheur l'immense privilège d'être le
parrain de l'occasion de présenter un
domaine que j'aime bien versé 2 parle
également avec tous ceux qui consacrent
leurs loisirs au jardin ils sont donc de
plus en plus nombreux car il est vrai
que jamais a souvent été un petit peu
mis de côté le jardin est un peu ce
vieil homme cette vieille dame un peu
oisive à la retraite qu ils s'extasient
devant la poussée des tomates ou la
fortification d'inscrits mais c'est
autre chose c'est aussi une philosophie
je suis très heureux de constater que
parole de journée donne la parole aux
jardiniers et permettra surtout à des
centaines de propriétaires et des
d'amateurs de montrer d'ouvrir leur
jardin et de faire découvrir des
merveilles
l'intérêt de cette manifestation c'est
justement de mettre en relation les
jeunes et les moins jeunes les âmes et
les femmes les professionnels et les
amateurs et que l'on échange que l'on
communique en un mot que l'on donne
envie à l'autre soit d'apprendre soit de
s'améliorer lorsque je rencontrais des
amateurs il ya quoi
des soupes 15 ans la majorité était à la
retraite aujourd'hui on peut dire que
les 30-40 ans sont devenus importants en
un mot quand on assiste à une conférence
sur le jardin on peut se dire que
finalement la population représente à
peu près ce qu'elle au niveau national
il ya des jeunes et des moins jeunes des
actifs et des retraités il ya des
brouilles à des moches les hommes il ya
les vins il ya de tout le monde du
jardin est devenu dans la pratique
l'image de ce qu'est la société
française alain baraton parent de parole
de jardiniers qui pour l'ouverture de
l'événement donnera une conférence
problématique de l'eau et embellissement
des jardins du domaine rendez vous le 14
juin à versailles à 14 heures du côté du
trianon
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine aux mêmes
horaires pour une nouvelle édition
excellent week end sur notre antenne à
lundi